Professor Shelly Kagan:
Last time I sketched the
deprivation account.
That's a story or theory about
what it is about death that
makes it bad.
What's bad about death is the
fact that, because you're dead,
because you don't exist,
you're deprived of the good
things in life.
Being dead isn't intrinsically
bad.
It's not like it's an
unpleasant experience.
But it's comparatively bad.
You're worse off by virtue of
the fact that you're not getting
the things that you would get,
were you still alive.
If I'm dead I can't spend time
with my loved ones.
I can't look at sunsets.
I can't listen to music.
I can't discuss philosophy.
The deprivation account says,
what's bad about death is the
fact that you're deprived of the
good things in life.
Now, that seems pretty
plausible, as a basic story
goes.
But as we also saw last time,
there are some philosophical
puzzles about how it could be.
The question of when is death
bad for you, and even more
importantly and more
essentially,
there's the difficulty of
asking ourselves,
do we really believe it's
possible for something to be bad
for you,
when you don't even exist?
We saw a series of difficult
choices.
If we don't throw in an
existence requirement,
if we don't say--to put it more
positively,
if we say things can be bad for
you even if you don't exist at
all, then we're forced to say
that things are bad for Larry.
You'll recall that Larry was
our name for a potential person,
somebody who could have come
into existence but never
actually does or will come into
existence.
Well, talk about people who are
deprived of the good things in
life, Larry's completely
life.
If we think it doesn't matter
whether or not you exist,
for things to be bad for you,
then we have to say,
"Oh, things are bad for Larry."
And not just Larry,
but all of the 1.5 million,
billion, billion,
billion never-to-be-born
people.
The number of potential people
is just staggering.
And if we throw away an
existence requirement,
we have to say it's a moral
tragedy of unspeakable
proportions that these people
are never born,
that they never come into
existence.
Now, there are philosophers who
are prepared to say that.
But if you're not prepared to
say that, it looks as though
you've got to accept some kind
of existence requirement.
Why don't we feel sorry for
Larry and his billions upon
billions of never-to-be-born
compatriots?
Because, indeed,
they don't exist.
They're merely possible.
And we might say,
you've got to exist in order
for something to be bad for you.
But once we say that,
it seems we're running towards
the position that,
in that case,
death can't be bad for me,
because of course,
when I'm dead,
I don't exist.
So how can anything be bad for
me?
I proposed at the end of class
last time that we could try to
solve this problem by
distinguishing between two
versions of the existence
requirement--a more modest
version and the bolder version.
The bolder version says,
"In order for something to be
bad for you, you've got to exist
at the very time that it's
happening."
If we say that,
then indeed,
we can say, "It's not bad that
Larry doesn't exist,
because he doesn't exist
now."
So there's nothing--even if we
wanted to think that there are
good things he could be having,
that's not bad for him to not
have them.
He doesn't exist now.
But it also,
if we go all the way to the
bold existence requirement,
we have to say,
"Look, when I'm dead that won't
be bad for me,
because, well,
I won't exist then."
But instead of accepting the
bold existence requirement,
we might settle for something a
little bit less demanding,
the thing I dub "the modest
existence requirement."
In order for something to be
bad for you, there has to have
been a time, some time or the
other, when you exist.
You've got to,
as it were, exist at least
briefly in order to get
into the club,
as we might put it,
of those creatures,
those possible creatures that
we care about and are concerned
about morally.
You have to have gotten in the
club by at least having existed
for some period of time.
But once you're in the club,
things can be bad for you,
even if you don't happen to
exist at that particular moment.
If we accept the modest
existence requirement,
then we can say,
it's not bad that Larry doesn't
exist, because,
well, Larry doesn't get into
the club.
In order to get into the club
of things that we feel sorry
for, you have to have existed at
least some moment or the other.
Larry and the billions upon
billions upon billions of
potential people who never
actually come into existence,
they don't satisfy the
requirement of having existed at
some time or the other.
So we don't have to feel sorry
for them.
But we can feel sorry for
somebody who died last week at
the age of 10 because we can
say, well, they existed,
albeit very briefly.
And so they're in the club of
beings that we can feel sorry
for and say, look,
it's bad for them that they're
not still alive.
Think of all the good things in
life they would be getting if
they were still alive.
So the modest existence
requirement allows us to avoid
both extremes.
Maybe then that's the position
that we should accept.
It may be, on balance,
the best possible view here.
But I just want to emphasize
that even the modest existence
requirement is not without its
counterintuitive implications.
Consider somebody's life.
Suppose that somebody's got a
nice long life.
Comes into existence,
leads--lives 10,20,
30,40, 50,60,
70,80, 90 years.
Nice life.
Now, imagine that we bring it
about that instead of living 90
years, they have a somewhat
shorter life--10,20,
30,40, 50 years.
We've caused them to die after
50 years as opposed to the 90
years they might have otherwise
had.
Well, we can say,
look, that's worse for them--to
live merely 50 years instead of
the full 90 or 100 years.
And if we accept the modest
existence requirement,
we can say that,
because after all,
whether you live 50 years or 90
years, you did exist at some
time or the other.
So the fact that you lost the
40 years you otherwise would
have gotten, well,
that's bad for you.
There.
Fair enough.
That gives us the answer we
want.
That's not counterintuitive.
Now, imagine that instead of
living 50 years,
the person lives only 10,20
years and then dies.
Well, that's worse still.
Think of all the extra goods
they would have gotten if only
they hadn't died then.
And if I caused them to die
after 20 years instead of 50 or
90 years, I've made things worse
and worse.
Imagine that I caused them to
die after one year.
Worse still.
All this is perfectly intuitive.
The shorter their life,
the worse it is for them,
the more they're deprived of
the good things in life.
So 90-year life, not bad.
50-year life, worse.
10-year life, worse still.
One-year life, worse still.
One-month life, worse still.
One day life, worse still.
One-minute life, worse still.
One-second life, worse still.
Now, imagine that I bring it
about that the person never
comes into existence at all.
Oh, that's fine.
See?
That's the implication of
accepting the modest existence
requirement.
If I shortened the life they
would have had so completely
that they never get born at all,
or they never come into
existence at all,
then they don't satisfy the
requirement of having existed at
some time or the other.
So although we were making
things worse and worse and worse
and worse and worse as we
shortened the life,
when we finally snip out that
last little fraction of a
second, it turns out we didn't
make things worse at all.
Now we haven't done anything
objectionable.
That's, it seems,
what you've got to say if you
accept the modest existence
requirement.
Of course, if we didn't have an
existence requirement at all,
we could say,
"Well look, worst of all,
never to have been born at
all."
Fair enough.
But if you say that,
then you've got to feel sorry
for Larry.
You've got to feel sorry for
the 1.5 million billion,
billion, billions.
So which view is it that on
balance is the--I don't want to
say "most plausible."
I think when we start thinking
about these puzzles,
every alternative seems
unattractive in its own way.
Maybe the most we could hope
for is, which is the least
implausible thing to say
here?
I'm not altogether certain.
Let me turn to one more trouble
or problem or puzzle for the
deprivation account.
And this particular puzzle
arises whether or not we accept
an existence requirement,
whether or not we accept a bold
existence requirement,
a modest existence requirement,
or no existence requirement,
because we're going to deal
with somebody who actually does
exist at some time or the other,
namely you or me.
This is actually a puzzle that
some of you may have written
your paper on,
because it's the puzzle about
Lucretius,
the puzzle that Lucretius gives
us.
It's not a direct quote,
but Lucretius basically says,
look, most of us are upset and
anxious at the fact that we're
going to die.
We think death is bad for us.
There'll be this period after
my death in which I won't exist.
And the deprivation account
helps say why that's bad,
because during this period of
nonexistence,
you're not enjoying the good
things in life.
Fair enough,
says Lucretius,
but wait a minute.
The period after you die isn't
the only period during
which you don't exist.
It's not the only period in
which if only you were still
alive, you could still be
enjoying the good things in
life.
There's another period of
nonexistence.
It's the period before my birth.
I think I've just switched the
timeline here,
but all right.
Imagine this is the period
before my birth.
Just like there'll be an
infinite period after my death
in which I won't exist,
and realizing that fills us
with dismay, there was,
of course, an infinite period
before I came into existence.
Well, if nonexistence is so bad
and by the deprivation account
it seems that we want to say
that it is,
shouldn't I be upset at the
fact that there was this
eternity before I was born?
But, says Lucretius,
that's silly,
right?
Nobody's upset about the fact
that there was an eternity
before they were born.
In which case,
it doesn't make any sense to be
upset about the eternity after
you die of nonexistence.
Well, Lucretius doesn't offer
this as a puzzle.
Lucretius offers this as an
argument that we should not be
concerned about the fact that
we're going to die.
Most philosophers aren't
willing to go with Lucretius all
the way to the end of the bus,
bus route.
Most philosophers want to say
there's got to be something
wrong with that argument
someplace.
There's got to be some-- Well,
what are the possibilities
here?
One possibility is indeed to
just agree with him,
right?
Nothing bad about the eternity
before I was born.
So, nothing bad--of the
eternity of nonexistence.
So nothing bad about the
eternity of nonexistence after I
die.
That's one possibility,
to agree with Lucretius.
Second possibility is to say,
look, Lucretius,
you're right.
We really do need to treat
these two eternities of
nonexistence on a par.
But we could turn it around.
Instead of saying with
Lucretius, nothing bad about
this one, so nothing bad about
this one,
maybe we should say instead,
something bad about the one
after we die,
and so something bad about the
one before we were born.
Maybe we should just stick to
the deprivation account and not
lose faith in it.
The deprivation account says
it's bad that there's this
period after we die,
because if only we weren't dead
then, we would still be able to
enjoy the good things in life.
Maybe we should say,
look, similarly then,
when the deprivation account
tells us it's bad that there's
this period before we come into
existence,
when we don't exist.
Because if only we had existed
then, we'd be able to enjoy the
good things in life.
Maybe Lucretius was right,
we have to treat both periods
the same.
But he's wrong in thinking we
shouldn't think either period is
bad.
Maybe we should think
both periods are bad.
Well, that's a possibility.
What other possibilities are
there?
Another possibility is to say,
Lucretius, you're right,
there are two periods of
nonexistence,
but there's a justification for
treating them differently.
They're asymmetrical in a way
that makes sense from the point
of view of what we should care
about.
Well, it's easy to say
that.
The puzzle--most philosophers
want to take that last way out.
They want to say there's
something that explains why it
makes sense, why it's
reasonable,
to care about the eternity of
nonexistence after my death,
but where that doesn't apply to
the eternity of nonexistence
before my birth.
And then the puzzle is to point
to a difference that would
justify that kind of rationally
asymmetrical treatment of the
two periods.
It's easy to say it's
okay, it's reasonable to treat
them differently.
The philosophical challenge is
to point to something that
explains or justifies that.
Now, a very common response is
to say something like this.
Look, consider the period after
my death.
I'm no longer alive.
I have lost my life.
In contrast,
the period before my birth,
although I'm not alive,
I have not lost my life.
I have never yet been alive.
And so, of course,
you can't lose something you've
never yet had.
So what's worse,
this answer suggests,
about the period after death,
is the fact that death involves
loss,
whereas prenatal nonexistence
does not involve loss.
And so, the conclusion comes,
and now we see why it's okay to
care more about that one than
this one, the one after death
and the one before birth.
Because the one after death
involves loss,
and the one before birth does
not.
Very, very common response,
but I'm inclined to think that
can't be an adequate answer.
It's true, of course,
that this period involves loss,
because the very definition of
"loss" is,
you don't have something that
at an earlier time you did have.
So this period involves loss.
But the period before birth
does not involve loss,
because although I don't have
life,
I haven't, previous to the
period, had life,
so I haven't lost
anything.
Of course, there's another
thing that's true about this
prenatal period,
to wit, I don't have life and
I'm going to get it.
So I don't yet have something
that's going to come in the
future.
That's not true about the
post-life period.
I've lost life.
But it's not true of this
period that I don't have life
and I'm going to get it in the
future.
So this period involves
loss.
Interesting.
In fact, we don't have a name
for this other state,
where you don't yet have
something that you'll get later,
but you don't yet have it.
Let's call that,
not loss, let's call it
"schmoss," okay?
So during this period,
there's a loss of life,
but no schmoss of life.
And in this period,
there's no loss of life,
but there's a schmoss of life.
And now we need to ask,
as philosophers,
why do we care more about
loss of life than
schmoss of life?
What is it about the fact that
we don't have something that we
used to, that makes it worse
than not having something that
we're going to?
It's easy to overlook the
symmetry here,
because we've got this nice
word "loss," and we don't have
this word "schmoss."
But that's not really
explaining anything,
it's just pointing to the thing
that needs explaining.
Why do we care more about not
having what once upon a time we
did, than we care about not
will?
Well, there's some other
proposals that we might make.
A couple of them have actually
been sketched in some of your
reading.
So for example,
Tom Nagel, in his essay on
death says, look,
here's the difference.
It's easy enough to
imagine--and indeed for there to
actually be a possibility of--my
living longer.
Suppose I die at the age of 80
and if I didn't die,
then I'd continue living
90,100, what have you.
There it is.
It's still me.
When you imagine me with an
earlier--rather with living
longer, you're imagining
me living longer.
To use the vocabulary that we
introduced in thinking about
some of Plato's arguments,
we might say although --suppose
I die at age 80--that's a fact
about me, it's a
contingent fact about me.
It's not a necessary fact about
me that I died at 80.
Suppose at 80 I get hit by a
car.
It's not a necessary truth
about me that I got hit by a
car.
I could have not gotten hit by
a car, and lived to the ripe old
age of 90 or 100.
When you die is not an
essential feature of you,
so it's easy for us to think
about the possibility in which I
live longer.
But, says Nagel,
when I try to imagine what
would the alternative be,
if I'm going to be upset about
the prenatal nonexistence,
we have to imagine my being
born earlier.
I was born in 1954.
Should I be upset about the
fact that I was born in 1954
instead of 1944?
That's the analog of being
upset about the fact that I die
in whatever it is,
2044 instead of living to 2054.
Nagel says, but look,
when you try to think about the
possibility in which instead of
being born in 1954,
I was born in 1944--and for the
rest of you, you've got to plug
in your own birthdates--Nagel
says you can't do it.
The date of my death is a
contingent fact about me.
But the date of my birth
is not a contingent fact about
me.
And by birth we don't really
mean when I came out of the
womb.
That could be changed,
perhaps by having been
delivered prematurely,
or through Caesarean,
or what have you.
We really mean the time at
which I come into existence.
Let's suppose it's the time
when the egg and the sperm join.
That's not a contingent moment
in my story.
That's an essential
moment in my life story.
How could that be?
We say, couldn't my parents
have had sex earlier,
10 years earlier?
Sure they could have.
But remember,
if they had had sex 10 years
earlier, it would have been a
different egg and a different
sperm coming together,
so it wouldn't be me.
It would be some sibling of
mine that, as it happens,
never got born.
But if, had they had sex 10
years earlier,
some sibling would have been
born.
That's not me being born
earlier.
Different sperm,
different egg makes for a
different person.
So you can't--you can say the
words, "if only I'd been born
earlier," but it's not actually
metaphysically possible.
Well, it's an intriguing
suggestion, but I think it can't
quite be right,
or at the very least,
it cannot be the complete story
about how to answer Lucretius'
puzzle.
Suppose we've got a fertility
clinic that has some sperm on
hold, and has some eggs on hold,
in the sperm bank,
in the egg bank,
what have you.
And they keep them here frozen
until they're ready to use them.
And they thaw them out in
whatever it is,
2020.
And then the person's born.
Of course, he could go back.
He could look back and say,
if only they had put my sperm
and egg together 10 years
earlier.
That would still be me.
After all, very same sperm,
very same egg,
makes for the very same person.
So if only they had combined my
sperm and egg 10 years earlier,
I would have been born 10 years
earlier.
Well, so Nagel's wrong in
saying it's not possible to
imagine being born earlier.
In at least some cases, it is.
Yet, if we imagine somebody
like this, somebody who's an
offspring of this kind of
fertility clinic,
and we ask, would they be upset
that they weren't born earlier?
again, it still seems as though
most people would say,
"No, of course not."
So the Nagel answer doesn't
seem to me to be an adequate
one.
Well, there's another possible
answer.
This is Fred Feldman's answer,
also in the one of the papers
that you've read.
Fred Feldman says--Nagel's a
contemporary philosopher,
Fred Feldman's a contemporary
philosopher.
Feldman says,
when I imagine--suppose I get
killed by the bus in 2044,
and if I imagine if only I
hadn't died then,
what is it that we imagine?
We imagine instead of living 80
years, living 90 or 95 or more.
We imagine a longer life.
But what is it that happens
when I say, if only I'd been
born earlier?
Well, says Feldman,
you don't actually imagine a
longer life, you just
shift the entire life and
start it earlier.
After all, suppose we just
said--especially if I had asked
you this question before setting
all of this up--but if only
you'd been born in 1800.
Nobody thinks,
"Oh, if only I'd been born in
1800, I'd still be alive.
I'd be 200 years old."
You think, "Oh,
if I'd been born in 1800,
I would have died in 1860,1870,
1880," whatever it is.
When we imagine being born
earlier, we don't imagine a
longer life.
Nothing better about having a
life earlier,
according to the deprivation
account.
But when we imagine not dying
when we actually die,
we say, "If only I died in 2050
instead of 2040,"
it's not that we imagine having
been born later.
We don't shift the life forward.
We imagine a longer life.
So, Feldman says,
no wonder, no surprise that you
care about the nonexistence
after death.
Because when you imagine
that being different,
you imagine a longer
life.
But when you start thinking
about the nonexistence before
birth and you imagine
that being different,
you don't imagine more
goods in life,
you just imagine them taking
place at a different time.
Well, that's an interesting
possibility, I suppose.
It doesn't seem to me--again,
that it's got to be--maybe it's
part of the story,
but it doesn't seem like it's
going to be the complete story.
Because we could imagine cases
where the person just thinks,
look, if only I'd been born
earlier, I would have had
a longer life.
Let's suppose that next week
astronomers discover the
horrible fact that there's an
asteroid that's about to land on
the Earth and wipe out all life.
So here it is,
it's going to come on January
1,2008.
And there you are,
at whatever your age is,
20 years old,
21 years old,
on January-on December 31,2008
thinking, I've only had 20 years
of life.
If only I'd been born earlier.
If only, instead of being born,
whenever it was,
I'd been born 10 years earlier,
I would have had 30 years of
life instead of 20 years of
life.
That seems perfectly
intelligible.
So it does seem as though,
if we put our head into it,
we can get ourselves into
thought experiments where we
say,
yeah, don't just shift the
life, make it longer.
But instead of making it longer
in the post-death direction,
make it longer in the pre-birth
direction.
Again, you can imagine somebody
saying, "Yeah,
and when we do that,
we should feel the same."
It doesn't really matter which
direction it goes.
So symmetry is the right answer
after all.
When I think about the asteroid
example, I find myself thinking,
huh, maybe symmetry is
the right way to go here.
Maybe Feldman's right,
that normally we just shift
instead of extending.
But if I'm careful to extend,
maybe that really is bad
that I didn't get started sooner
and have a longer life in that
direction.
Well, here's one other answer
that's been proposed.
This is by yet another
contemporary philosopher,
Derek Parfit.
Parfit says,
it's true that when I think
about the nonexistence after I
die,
that's loss,
whereas the nonexistence before
I'm born, that's not loss,
that's mere schmoss.
And it's true that we need an
explanation about why loss is
worse than schmoss.
But we can see that this is not
an arbitrary preference on our
part, because in fact,
it's part of a quite general
pattern we have of caring about
the future in a way that we
don't care about the past.
This is a very deep fact about
human caring.
We are oriented towards the
future and concerned about what
happens in it,
in a way that we're not
oriented and concerned about
what happened in the past.
Parfit's got a very nice
example to bring the point home.
He says, imagine that you've
got some condition,
some medical condition that
will kill you unless you have an
operation.
So fair enough,
you're going to have the
operation.
This will allow you to live
your life.
Unfortunately,
in order to perform the
operation, they can't have you
anesthetized.
You have to be awake,
perhaps in order to tell the
surgeon "Yeah,
that's where it hurts,"
whatever it is.
Sort of like when the dentist
pokes and says,
"Does this hurt?
Does that hurt?"
So you've got to be awake
during the operation and it's a
very painful operation.
We can't give you pain killer,
because then you won't be able
to point out,
does this hurt,
does that hurt,
and so forth and so on.
Since we can't give you pain
killer, all we can do is this.
So, you'll be awake during
this, basically being tortured.
You'll be awake being tortured.
It's still worth doing it,
because this will cure the
condition, so then you'll have a
nice long life.
Since we can't give you pain
killers and we can't put you
out, all we're going to do is,
what we will do is this:
After the operation is over,
we'll give you this very
powerful medication,
which will give you short-term,
sort of very localized,
amnesia.
You won't remember anything
about the operation itself.
So you won't have to at least
to dwell upon these horrible
memories of having been
tortured.
Those will be completely wiped
out.
Okay, so painful operation.
You're awake during it.
After the operation,
you're given this thing that
makes you forget whether you've
had the operation,
anything about the operation at
all.
And that the preceding 24 hours
will be completely wiped out.
So you're in the hospital and
you wake up and you ask
yourself, "Huh,
have I had the operation yet or
not?"
Don't know, right?
Because of course,
if I haven't had it,
no wonder I don't remember it,
but if I have had it,
I would have been given that
temporary sort of localized
amnesia.
So of course I wouldn't know
whether or not I've had it.
So you ask the nurse,
"Have I had the operation yet
or not?"
She says, "I don't know,
we have a couple on the hall
today who are,
some of whom have had it and
some of whom are scheduled to
have it later today.
I don't remember which one you
are.
Let me go look at your file.
I'll come back and I'll tell
you."
So she wanders off.
She's going to come back in a
minute or two.
And as you're waiting for her
to come back,
you ask yourself,
what do you want the answer to
be?
Are you indifferent,
or do you care whether you're
one of the people who's already
had it, or somebody who hasn't
yet had it?
Now, if you're like Parfit,
and for that matter,
like me, then you're going to
say, of course I care.
I want it to be the case that
I'm one of the people who's
already had the
operation.
I don't want to be one of the
people who hasn't yet had the
operation.
You might say,
how can that make any sense?
Your life's going to have the
operation sooner or later.
At some point in your life
history, that operation is going
to have occurred.
And so there's the same amount
of pain and torture,
regardless of whether you're
one of the people that had it
yesterday or one of the people
that's going to have it
tomorrow.
But for all that,
says Parfit,
the fact of the matter is
perfectly plain,
that we do care.
We want the pain to be in the
past.
We don't want the pain to be in
the future.
We care more about what's
happening in the future than we
care about what's happening in
the past.
That being the case,
no surprise we care about the
nonexistence in the future in a
way we don't care about the
nonexistence in the past.
Well, that may be right as far
as explanation goes,
but we might still wonder
whether or not it's any kind of
justification.
The fact that we've got this
deep-seated asymmetrical
attitude towards time doesn't in
any way,
as far as I can see,
yet tell us whether or not
that's a justified
attitude.
Maybe evolution built us to
care about the future in a way
that we don't care about the
past and this shows up in lots
of places,
including Parfit's hospital
case, including our attitude
towards loss versus schmoss,
and so forth and so on.
But the fact that we've got
this attitude doesn't yet show
that it's a rational
attitude.
How could we show that it's a
rational attitude?
Well, maybe we'd have to start
doing some heavy-duty
metaphysics, if what we've been
doing so far isn't yet
heavy-duty enough.
Maybe we need to talk about the
difference between--the
metaphysical difference between
the past and the future.
The past is fixed,
the future is open,
the direction of time.
Maybe somehow we could bring
all these things in and explain
why our attitudes towards time
make sense.
I'm not going to go there.
All I want to say is it's not
altogether obvious what the best
answer to Lucretius' puzzle is.
So when I say,
as I have said--and I'm going
to say it many times over the
course of the remaining
weeks--that the central thing
that's bad about death is the
fact that you're deprived of the
good things in life,
when I make use of the
deprivation account,
I don't mean to suggest
everything is sweetness and
light with regard to the
deprivation account.
I think there are some residual
puzzles about how it could be
that death is bad.
And in particular,
how it could be that the
deprivation account puts its
finger on what's bad about
death.
But for all that,
it seems to me the right way to
go.
It seems to me that the
deprivation account does put its
finger on the central bad thing
about death.
Most centrally,
what's bad about death is that
when you're dead,
you're not experiencing the
good things in life.
Death is bad for you because
you don't have what life would
bring you, if only you hadn't
died.
All right.
If that's right,
should we conclude,
in fact, do we have to
conclude--if death is bad
because of it's a deprivation,
then if I wasn't dead,
I wouldn't be deprived--so
doesn't it follow then that the
best thing of all is never to
die at all,
to wit, immortality?
If it's bad--suppose I get hit
by a truck next week,
that's bad, because if only I
hadn't gotten hit by a truck,
I might have lived another
20,30 years, whatever.
I would have gotten the good
things in life that would have
been better for me.
Ah, but when I die of whatever
it is, some heart disease at age
80, that's bad maybe because if
only I didn't have heart
disease,
I could have lived another
10,15, 20 years,
gotten more good things in
life.
If only I hadn't died at 100,
I would have gotten more good
things in life.
If only I hadn't died at 500,
I would have gotten more good
things in life.
Whenever it is I die,
won't it always be true,
if we accept the deprivation
account,
that if only I hadn't died
then, I would have gotten more
good things in life?
And so whenever it is you die,
death is bad for you.
So the best thing for you would
be never to die,
immortality.
Two questions really that we
need to ask.
One is: Does consistency,
does logic, require somebody
who accepts the deprivation
account--does consistency
require that if you accept the
deprivation account,
you believe immortality's a
good thing?
Second question:
Even if logic doesn't require
that, is it true that
immortality's a good thing?
Let me start with the first
one, because I think that's the
easier one.
Logic alone,
logic plus the consistency
requirement--rather and the
deprivation account--logic alone
doesn't require us to say
immortality's a good thing.
Why?
Because strictly speaking,
what the deprivation account
says is, death is bad insofar as
you're deprived of the good
things in life by virtue of not
existing.
If only you hadn't gotten hit
by that truck,
you would have gone on to an
exciting life in your career as
a professional dancer.
You would have had a family,
or what have you.
Whatever it is.
You would have traveled around
the world.
Life would have given you a lot
of great things and you get
deprived of those great things,
that's why it's bad that you
got hit by the truck.
That is to say,
death is bad,
when it's bad,
by virtue of the fact that it
deprives you of the good things
in life.
But suppose--we don't yet know
whether this could actually
happen, but here we're just
talking about logical
possibilities--suppose that
there's no more good things for
life to give you.
Then when you're deprived of
life by death,
you're not being deprived of
any good things,
and so it's not bad for you to
be dead at that point.
Death is only bad,
according to the deprivation
account, when there are good
things that would have come your
way.
When, as we might put it,
on balance, the life you would
have had would have continued to
be good for you.
When that happens,
then to lose that good bit of
life, that's bad for you.
But if it should turn out that
what life would have had
hereafter, instead of being
good, would have been hellish,
it's not bad for you to avoid
that.
It might actually be
good for you to avoid it.
So, even if we accept the
deprivation account,
we're not committed to the
claim that death is always bad.
We have to look and see,
what would life actually hold
out for us?
Logic alone,
plus the deprivation account,
doesn't force us to say
immortality would be a good
thing.
After all--this is really a
crucial point to
understand--things that are good
for you in limited quantities
can become bad for you if you
get more and more and more and
more of them.
Well, I love chocolate.
So suppose somebody comes up to
me with a box of Godiva
chocolate, offers me a couple of
chocolates.
I say, "Wonderful!
I love Godiva chocolate."
And then they give me some more
and some more.
Twenty pieces of chocolate.
Well, you know,
by the time I got 20 pieces of
chocolate, I'm not sure right
now if I really want the 21^(st)
piece.
But you keep giving me some
more.
Thirty pieces of chocolate,
40 pieces of chocolate,
100 pieces of chocolate.
At some point--I've never
actually had his much chocolate;
I don't know what the point is,
but at some point--I'm
going to say,
you know,
although the first 10,20,
30 pieces of chocolate,
those were good,
but giving me the 21^(st) piece
of chocolate or the 50^(th)
piece of chocolate,
no longer good.
Logically, at least,
it could happen.
Logically, it could happen that
although in quantities,
small quantities,
50 years,
60 years, 100 years,
life is good,
at some point,
maybe life would turn bad for
us.
Just like being force-fed more
and more chocolate.
And if it did turn bad for us,
the deprivation account would
allow us to say,
oh, at that point,
dying's not bad for you.
Well, that's all that logic
tells us.
Logic simply tells us we don't
have to believe
immortality's a good thing.
But for all that,
it could still be a good
thing.
So that's question number two.
Let's ask, what should we think
about the prospect of living
forever?
Would it, in fact,
be better and better and
better?
Somebody dies at age 10 by some
horrible disease,
better if they'd made it up to
40.
Somebody dies at age 40,
better if they'd made it up to
80.
Somebody dies at age 80,
better if they'd made it to
100,120.
Is it true that life would get
better and better and better,
the longer it is?
Now, in asking this question,
we have to be careful to be
clear about what exactly we're
imagining.
Here's one way to try to
imagine that story.
Imagine that life is sort of
the way it works now,
with the kinds of changes that
bodies undergo as they get
older.
But instead of those changes
basically killing you at 80,90,
or 100, they don't.
You get more and more of those
changes, but they never actually
kill you.
This is the sort of thought
experiment that Jonathan Swift
undertakes in the passage from
Gulliver's Travels that
I've had you look at.
He imagines Gulliver coming to
a country where a subset of the
people live forever,
immortals.
And at first,
Gulliver says,
"Oh, isn't this wonderful?"
But he forgot to think about
the fact that if the kinds of
changes that we undergo continue
to accumulate,
then you're getting older.
Not just older,
but weaker, in more and more
discomfort, senility sets in
with a vengeance,
until eventually you've got
these creatures that live
forever, but their mind is gone,
and they're sort of in pain and
they can't do anything because
their body's utterly infirm and
diseased and sick.
That's not a wonderful thing to
have.
If immortality was like
that, says Swift,
that would be horrible.
For an immortality like that,
death would be a blessing.
And Montaigne,
in the essay that I've had you
look at, says indeed,
death is a blessing,
because it puts an end to the
pain and suffering and misery
that afflict us in our old age.
Well, all of that seems right,
but I suppose we'd be forgiven
for thinking,
look,
when we wanted to be immortal,
we didn't want this kind
of life going on and on and on
with the same trajectory,
the same downward trajectory.
We sort of wanted to live
forever, hail and hearty and
healthy.
So even if the real world
wouldn't allow us that,
let's just ask science fictiony
whether or not in fact living
forever would be good.
Isn't it at least true that in
principle, living forever could
be good?
You've got to imagine changing
some of the facts about what it
would be like to live forever.
So instead of asking the
question, the question I started
with, would it be good to live
forever?
--If you're not careful,
this is going to be like one of
those horror stories,
right?
Where you've got a couple of
wishes and you aren't careful
about how exactly you state the
wish.
And so you get what you want,
but it ends up being a
nightmare, right?
If you just tell the fairy who
gives you three wishes,
"I want to live forever,"
and you forgot to say "and be
sure to keep me healthy," well,
that's going to be a nightmare.
That's what Swift told us.
So let's be careful.
Let's throw in health and
anything else you want.
Throw in enough money to make
sure you're not poor for
eternity.
Wouldn't that be horrible,
to be healthy but
impoverished forever?
Throw in whatever you want.
All we need to ask at that this
point is, is there any way at
all to imagine immortality,
where immortality of that sort
would be a good thing?
Is there any way to imagine
existing forever where that
would be good for you,
forever?
Now, it's very tempting at this
point to say,
look, of course.
Nothing could be easier.
Just imagine being in
heaven forever,
right?
You're done, right?
You've got heavenly bliss.
Isn't this incredible?
Wouldn't we all love to be in
heaven forever?
The trouble is,
we were a little bit vague
about what exactly life is like
in heaven.
It's a striking fact that even
those religions that promise us
an eternity in heaven are rather
shy on the details.
Why?
Because, one might worry,
if you actually tried to fill
in the details,
this wonderful,
eternal existence ends up not
seeming so wonderful after all.
So imagine that what's going to
happen is that we all become
angels and we're going to spend
eternity singing psalms.
Now, I like psalms and I
actually enjoy rather singing
psalms at services.
On Saturday mornings,
I sing psalms in Hebrew and I
rather enjoy it.
But if you ask me:
What about the possibility of
an eternity of doing that?
That doesn't really seem so
desirable.
Bedazzled,
not the remake.
I haven't seen the remake,
but the original.
In the original,
there's a human character who
hooks up with the devil.
He meets the devil and he asks
the devil, "So why did you rebel
against God?"
The devil says,
"Well, I'll show you.
You sit here on the--" whatever
it was, the mailbox,
I think it was.
"I'll sit up here on the
mailbox," the devil says.
"And you dance around me and
say, Oh, praise the lord,
aren't you wonderful?
You're so magnificent.
You're so glorious.'"
And the human does this for a
while and he says,
"This has gotten really boring.
Can't we switch?"
And the devil says,
"That's exactly what I said."
Now, when you try to imagine
heaven singing psalms for
eternity, that doesn't seem so
attractive.
All right, so don't imagine
heaven singing psalms for
eternity.
Just imagine something else.
But what?
Imagine what?
This is the thought experiment
that I invite you to participate
in.
What kind of life can you
imagine, such that having that
life forever would be good?
Not just for another 10 years,
not just for another 100 years,
not just for another 1,000
years, or million years,
or a billion years.
Remember, eternity is a very,
very long time.
Forever goes on forever.
Can you describe an existence
that you would want to be stuck
with forever?
Now, it's precisely at this
point that Bernard Williams,
in another one of the papers I
had you take a look at--Bernard
Williams says no .
No kind of life would be one
that would be desirable and
attractive forever.
No kind of life at all.
In short, says Williams,
every life would eventually
become tedious and worse,
excruciatingly painful.
Every kind of life is a life
you would eventually want to be
rid of.
Immortality,
far from being a wonderful
thing, would be a horrible
thing.
Suppose, for the moment,
that we were to agree with
Williams.
What then should we say?
We might say--look,
at least when we're being
careful, if we agree that
immortality would be bad,
we can't say then that death,
per se, is bad.
The very fact that I am going
to die turns out not to be a bad
thing, because after all,
the only alternative to dying
is immortality.
And if immortality would be a
bad thing,
then death is not a bad
thing.
Death is a good thing.
We might say,
if we accept Williams' thought,
the fact of our mortality is
good rather than bad,
if immortality would eventually
be bad.
Now of course,
crucial to notice that even if
we say this, that doesn't mean
that when you get hit by a car
tomorrow, that that's good.
You don't have to say that.
You can still say it's a bad
thing that I got hit by a car
tomorrow, because after all,
if I hadn't gotten hit by a car
tomorrow, it's not as though I
would have been condemned to
immortality,
I just would have lived another
10 or 20 or 30 years.
And those years would have been
good ones for me.
And maybe even when I
die--let's suppose I live to the
ripe old age of 100--when I die
at 100,
I could perhaps still say,
it's a bad thing for me that I
die at the age of 100.
Because if I hadn't died now,
I might have lived another
10,20, 30 years and still
enjoyed things in life,
enjoyed playing with my great
grandchildren,
whatever it is.
To say that immortality is bad
is not to say it's a good thing
that we die when we do.
You can still believe
consistency--consistently--that
we die too soon.
Even if in principle,
eventually, sooner or later,
death would no longer be bad,
it could be that it comes too
soon for all of us.
Still, the question we want to
ask is, is there any way even to
imagine an immortal life
that would be worth having?
In principle,
could immortality be a good
thing?
Or, is Williams right,
that no, even in principle,
go as fantastic and science
fictiony as you want,
in principle an immortal life
could not be desirable?
So until next time,
I invite you to think that
question through.
If you're trapped into the
prospect of immortality,
what would the best kind
of immortal life be like?